is crisis enough
do well it's all that we're waiting for
is for because you know in spite of the
fact that we give lip service to the
idea of crisis you know when was the
last time any one of you murdered a rat
in an alley in order to get dinner
people did that all over europe in the
40s after the collapse of nazi germany
and that wasn't the end of the world
that was just a little european
political contra temps
so we're uh extremely spoiled i really
think what we need is for the screws to
be tightened so shock a little bit
and then you know
people i think it is coming i just hope
it's coming fast enough the trick you
see
is to make the omelet without breaking
the egg and
when well
the longer we hesitate
the more difficult it's going to be
somehow we have to
go undergo a total
transformation at every level and i
don't mean the patrons of excellent
institute i mean the patrons of the moz
hash house in cleveland they have to
undergo this total
you did you forgot about them
i asked about this people you know
sitting there watching tv drinking beer
you know are we talking about those
people too
well a buddhist would say yes you know
we cannot enter into enlightenment until
we carry the last sentient being with us
but my god what a taller
[Applause]
besides the excellent patrons what are
the audience
a culture can evolve no faster than it
can involve its language because if you
don't have words to talk about what
you're
pointing at then it's a private
experience
so what the the
forced evolution of language not the
force that sounds a little heavy-handed
the planned transformation of language
is what is necessary
yes repairing syntax we have to the
present time
been uh
uh
willing to allow language to just evolve
willy-nilly
and an example of the opposite case for
instance is the attempt to d
uh to eliminate sexism from our language
and the humor that it provokes the idea
that someone would use a and
tremendously ungainly word like chair
person
or an a a silly notion like her story
his story her story this kind of thing
and yet and yet the motivation i think
is very good people are saying
you cannot change your political
understanding until you consciously
consciously do something about your
language
the the germans could not have gasped
the jews if they had not had a
vocabulary which allowed them to see
jews as sub-human and that was the
phrase sub-human what's the word peter
subhuman
the under people and they the the sub
man
well my god once you have government
newspapers with this kind of thing being
banted about well then you just say you
know they're not people they're the
under people uh language gives
permission for all kinds of atrocities
and the potential for transformation now
as always in the political game our side
gets there second
you know we march up to take control of
the machinery of language creation and
we discover that joseph goebbels got
there first and madison avenue and so
forth and so on we are children in the
arts of propaganda they are extremely
expert nevertheless uh its
transformation of language that we have
to do one of the things i've suggested
and
met with great puzzlement even by the
inner faithful
is
this thing where i try to promote the
idea that we could change our view of
the world
into a more humane direction if we would
reform our calendar
if we would abandon the solar calendar
and that we're not playing on a level
field when we use the calendar and the
time
point of view of the the dominator
culture we need a lunar calendar that
has a procession against the solar year
so that the holidays slip and move so
that the notion of flow and flux is
primary rather than the notion of static
eternal forms
we are our metaphors in the broadest
sense meaning everybody from me to radix
and through the our metaphors will never
get a
fully reasonable hearing within a
context of solar paternal language the
deck is stacked yeah
before we took a break you started to
talk about why you thought we will end
up with artificial language
and could you maybe uh comment on how
you think this might enter into what
you've been what is this well not
exactly so much artificial language
somebody asked uh
about cetacean intelligence and life in
the seas
and uh
and this also goes to kathleen's work
i've tried to imagine
uh an ontological transformation of the
human form
rather than
a technological breakthrough of the more
ordinary sort and i try to do that
because it seems to me when you start
thinking about it that obviously
the first tool or one of the first tools
was language
language is a way of organizing
acoustical signals which are things in
the three-dimensional world they move
through air
language is a way of
organizing acoustical signals so that
they convey
intentionality
intentionality is an interior condition
of the mind
and
language is this bizarre
ability which must have burst rather
spontaneously on the scene
where suddenly we discovered that by
modulating acoustical signals we could
create models
in the minds of nearby fellow species
members
of our intentions
well uh the problem i mean and this set
us on the long road to this evening
but the problem is that uh
every um
language
is ultimately limited at its upper level
by the depth of the coding medium
and
a good example of this is smoke signals
this would be a terrible way to transmit
paradise loss yes
you see the the depth of the coding
medium is rather shallow it can say
we're here
or we'll be there in three days
but it can hardly say
uh you know south and south and
southward i we fled till it grew
wondrous cold and ice masked high went
floating by as green as emerald
small signals can't do that
acoustical language also has severe
depth of code constraints on it but it's
possible to imagine ontological
transformations of language which would
be very different
south and south and southward i we fled
till it grew wondrous cold and ice
masked high when floating by as green as
emerald